do you guys see kamala harris endorse
communism yeah
just just straight up straight up like
yeah
i mean i don't know like if she actually
you know signed off on that video being
posted on her account
or oh that's where she is yeah right
that is actually yeah you're right okay
so so hold on she didn't literally say
comrade we must you know start communism
she said
we must give people resources so that we
all end up in the same place
same thing and it was like a video
explaining how she said
granting people equal resources for
competition is not the way
we need to give them this equal
opportunities so that they it results in
uh you know we all end up in the same
place equal outcomes
right it's like if you give two people
rope that was like the gist of the
analogy and one person is unable to
climb
because they were starting from like a
lower platform right
but it was the same length of rope to
climb right right right so they always
use this argument to justify
communism and it's you can give to
people rope
there will never be in ethical
circumstances it's impossible so they
try and create a circumstance in the
video where one person's lower than the
other and it's like well welcome to
the world there's literally nothing you
can do can i can
from just personally like uh so we were
just down in in
in your basement earlier and where
you're setting up a skate park and it's
like
i might be physically taller than you
but you're a way better skater than me
right so you're going to get to that
six-foot ramp so so there's that i am so
like that's it just is what it is well
for context there's a
six foot tall half pipe in my basement
and
very tall ceilings and on top of one
side is
a lounge chair a coffee table a
refrigerator full of drinks and a tv
and it's called the vip lounge the only
way to get if you want to be in the vip
lounge you need only get into the vip
lounge
right some people are not going to be
able to get up that six foot ramp
because they don't have the skills or
they're not
like yeah it's basically just about
skill for the most part in strength can
you do it
and uh i i already had people jokingly
call me ableist
and i was like that's actually not true
because there's some really amazing
wheelchair
like yeah i feel like i've seen that
yeah yeah they would easily get up there
and then laugh and like you could you
can get some
some ripped guy who can't climb uh uh
you know vert wall unable to get up
there yeah and then you're gonna have
some doing a wheelchair up there being
like
you need the skills to pay the bills man
you know oh wait so you are allowed to
climb
you as long as you can get up i don't
care how you get up there oh you're
going to go up the wall
yeah yeah yeah you just blow yourself up
yeah but then people were like what
about someone in a wheelchair like i've
seen people in wheelchairs go up some
pretty like way bigger vert walls like
it's just about having the skills to do
it
yeah so anyway that kind of flies in the
face of the idea of
you know equal outcomes communism right
because there are different that's a
great that's
even we're actually going further than
this because it's
there are other ways to get up the
mountain absolutely what's also
frustrating about the left is not only
are they saying oh well if everyone
starts from the same place they must end
up at the same
outcome which we know is not true but
they the way that they determine whether
people are starting from the same place
isn't just by looking from where they're
starting from
they kind of do the inverse they look at
where they're finishing and if they're
not finishing at the same place then
they assume they must not have started
at the same place and that is that i
think is one of the biggest problems
because
i'm i as much as possible want to remove
barriers
to to success for everybody black people
white people
or you whatever it is i think there
should be you should have the chance to
succeed
the way that the left currently
determines whether you have that chance
or not
is whether you have actually
accomplished whatever it may be and if
you
haven't assume it's suppression and that
gets to the idea of
who who decides the value distinction of
what is that place everybody wants to
get to is it is it a certain salary
or is it a family size or is it
travel or like there's so many different
we have
we have live in this like amazing world
we really do there's like so much to do
there's so much you can you can have and
those are the types of opportunities
that i'd like to open
up the idea of of choice but there's no
there's no upper limit like so yeah i
often
we talk about all the time uh you know
various points
rockefeller would be in awe of the
comfort we live in
if he was transported right now oh yeah
the richest man the oil baron
the the people running the east india
trading company if they came here they'd
be like
the water is clean and you don't get
parasites and you can take a shower like
whenever you want just like turn a knob
and then
boom there's hot water like i always
bring this up and try time travel
discussions oh i wish i lived in this
period no you really don't you
really don't wish you lived in the past
like three months at sea
20 of the people on the ship would die
no you're like we'll make it there some
and then you
you make it to north america and it's
like we're here and you're like there's
literally nothing on the shore i know
start building
well that's what my mom is one of those
women who loves period romances where
everyone's like wearing a bonnet
i i cannot when i'm watching those get
in a romantic mood because i'm just
thinking
everyone must have smelled bad take it
back yeah you can't take a bath if you
can't brush your teeth
i mean you probably have at least a
little bit of scurvy it's just it wasn't
it's not a romantic time
seriously you know there's actually
there's actually this whole um
and we're just totally fantastic right
now but um but but tim's allowing us i'm
totally doing this
um i'm a chris wallace moderator not a
christian
mr president um that in
in the middle ages that you ever notice
when you're reading anything from the
from medieval times that they always
talk about drinking meat like
all the time yeah so studies right
because they didn't have water clean
water so they knew that was clean
because it was purified
and so that that people just were like a
little bit more buzzed
all the time which explains a lot about
the middle ages
um and then this and then it's
right before the renaissance um coffee
is introduced to europe
okay makes sense so there's like this
whole idea of
is it you know you know your your
alcohol versus your caffeine
that makes sense a lot of sense what
were we talking about
oh yeah oh yeah communism oh right but
also
we were talking about how it wouldn't be
good to live in the past and how even
rockefeller would be in awe about all
the comforts we have now
i feel like that kind of attitude is why
now have you noticed the left
they they love talking about wealth
inequality now they no longer focus just
solely on the issue of poverty or
standard of living
they talk specifically about wealth
inequality and i think that's so good
because everything's great man like you
got poor people with clean running water
showers refrigerators and air
conditioning
yeah thank goodness and we have poor
people who are homeless for sure and we
have you have people who struggle to pay
their rent and get evicted and there's a
lot of you know problems in this country
i think we can we can you know find a
way to fix for sure
but the standard of living has become so
incredible
the question i think you're bringing up
is where would they be satisfied with
everyone being
what's that marker where it's like okay
here's where everyone should be
and they'll tell you it's like clean
healthcare and clothes and they give you
they they want everyone to have a
general middle class stand of standard
of living
which is like living like a king for the
rest of the world
the idea that you could have an
apartment you know with a one
one bedroom apartment clean running
water refrigerator two weeks vacation
clothes
insurance your health care stuff's
covered you're making probably 80 to
100k a year that's
where you'd probably be depending on
where you're in the us you are in like
the .01
of the world right the the average
american making like 30 to 40k
is the one percent of the world so what
they're basically saying is this is a
fantastic thing
i i was in brazil during this uh protest
in 2013
and i went to the favelas which are the
shanty towns the poorest of the poor
live there they just build randomly on
top of each other
and this lady we were at her house
asking her about the protest what was
going on she had some kids who were
involved
and we asked her uh you know we we're
just talking to her
and she asked me in portuguese and they
translated why are the rich people
protesting in america
and i laughed and i was like that no who
and she said she mentioned the protest
and the guy was like oh she's talking
about
like occupy wall street stuff and i went
no no no
occupy wall street is like young people
and you know middle
middle class kind of people and like
left-leaning people angry with the banks
and and like the corruption in
government and then they
translate it to her and then she goes
she responds
everyone in america is rich right and i
laughed and i was like i'm in her favela
where the toilet had a pile of human
waste going up from like a week because
it didn't rain so they couldn't flush
and yeah she was wondering why it is
that americans
she wasn't saying i think it was a
translation thing she wasn't saying all
these rich people with monocles and hats
were going on oh harambe
say i demand change she was saying that
americans are protesting but they're so
rich why
have you have you read michael
schellenberger's new book no no because
he he actually talks about that
in brazil a lot and spending a lot of
time down there
but from more of a climate standpoint
but he said that when he went to
brazil that you know and they were
talking about um
you know chopping down parts of the rain
forest um
that you know he found out very quickly
that
it wasn't these this like mass operation
that it was like mostly
just poor farmers looking for more land
um that they could eke out and and clear
and clear it out and he said
you know really the best thing that we
can do is raise their
help raise living standards introduce
technologies
um actually create more of an industry
around this
so that instead of people having to do
it all on their own
that it can be more efficient land use
down there and
that will definitely help a lot more
than just placing these arbitrary
restrictions on everybody
you know i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna be a
little biased i i think it may be that
the left in this country doesn't
actually want to help anybody
they want to use these things as a
carrot dangling from a stick
vote for me that's all it says vote for
me and you'll get what you want
vote for me and we'll make your life
better they don't actually want to make
their lives better because then what are
they going to put on the end of the
stick
no more carrot yeah and i think i think
there are a lot of young
like social democrats or even just
flat-out socialists out there
who believe that capitalism is so evil
and so oppressive because they're
i mean frankly ignorant of what the rest
of the world looks like right they
see they're usually from upper middle
class backgrounds and they see a
homeless person and they think this is
terrible which it is
but they blame capitalism for it they
still don't understand that you know the
the amount of opportunity and even
relative uh comfort that someone in
america even a poor
person has compared to the rest of the
world is still
like very great and that's not to say
that capitalism is perfect it's just
merely the best system that we have
if there were a way to to do it you know
it's cost effective i've always said
like every
every high school student should be
required to spend two weeks in mexico
before they
before they graduate well a lot of uh
well everyone's going to call you racist
a lot of religions do have like service
trips and things like that where
you drive in the woods yeah you're
supposed to go how about appalachia
you know yeah something else mountain
top you know you have to leave the
country just
it's any place that has like serious
poverty that's nearby and to understand
that you know most of these people at
these protests are not
experiencing the extreme i mean these
kids
in in you know like uh
moorfield west virginia where you know
you're getting you're you're
you don't have toothpaste and you're sh
you're brushing your teeth like mountain
dew and stuff
like these stories that you hear and
it's like why you know and we just
we laugh at them we make fun of them
hollywood makes fun of them the only
time they make movies about them it's
some kind of horror movie
i got to tell my favorite story and
everybody who's listening is going to be
like i've heard tim says a million times
but my favorite example
of you know trump's strategy is when he
had that well done steak with ketchup
because poor people have well done
steaks with ketchup because they can't
afford good meat
and the media started laughing what an
idiot trump's so
dumb yeah well done with ketchup
goodness and that was basically
trump got the media to insult the
american people and poor people
they did something similar when trump
had those what are they college kids
over and they were having like
mcdonald's
or something like that all these media
snobs saying oh look mcdonald's
meanwhile
americans love mcdonald's trump really
trump really does love fast food though
i don't think that's i don't think
that's like a strategy on this part
they have actually been since since he
went through covet and everything
they've actually been trying to keep him
on like a
healthier diet salads and everything
else but i think i think i tweeted out
this morning that i heard that um since
today's like you know it is the last day
of the campaign
um he had a huge breakfast of like just
bacon and eggs
last presidential meal you know and and
and then he just
wanted that energy to go out but um he
said that the one
well i think every other day was a
couple of weeks ago but he had they
um he had two dinners like he had a
dinner before the rally and a dinner
afterwards
wow this is dude i would do this dude is
spry
he is he has more energy than i do i'm
not even i'm not even being hyperbolic
he asks i could not do the number of
rallies he does
i don't i don't he did five rallies per
day he talks for what an hour or two
so here's so i can walk through it so he
did he woke up in washington dc
yesterday morning
flies to detroit does his first rally in
detroit 11 a.m how long did he speak
about an hour and a half he's only
supposed to speak an hour he's spoken
in in snow flurries and like icy wind
that he was making fun of for
like the whole the whole speech um he
continues
four more rallies throughout the day
ends in miami florida
you know 80 degrees 40 degrees yeah you
see that tweet from that guy
who was like it must be a warmer in
florida does that work
in florida because he's not literally a
little
like these powers about is that hercula
poirot there
from agatha christie is this crap are
you about to are you about to
to solve the uh the death on the nile
you know okay so he goes to miami then
we're going to say so
overnight i believe overnight in either
doral or mar-a-lago
then then he kind of does the same path
backwards
he's doing that right now today where he
started in florida
he's going to end up then makes the
scranton uh pennsylvania then he's going
to end tonight
in michigan with a rally that's probably
gonna start around midnight
and then he's going back to dc after
that so it's
so it was michigan florida then florida
to michigan and then back
yeah and these are how many in one day
five five each day
five each day for an hour and a half
each rally hour an hour and a half yeah
tim does i do about three hours and 45
minutes
of speaking recorded content every day
and it is
brutal it is very difficult and most
people who do uh commentary like the
biggest names
do about three hours so i'm doing at the
high end or more than most
yeah you do a lot you do a lot how does
trump do more than me
like i'm i'm sitting here you can't see
because whenever she changes the camera
i yawn
the generator regeneration do you see
the lincoln project
i love that yeah it's so good regeneron
well did you see the latest one they did
with the kid in the in the bed
oh yeah oh
she hasn't seen it yet but they go to
they go to the kid and they said
trump the who won election trump
i thought you could only be elected
twice not anymore
but it doesn't even make sense because
even in like the lincoln projects ad
they're acknowledging that people would
still vote for right exactly
right so the the nugget of truth is that
trump keeps winning elections
yep trump won so it's like what what
reality do you live in where
it's it's a democracy you wanted yeah it
was it was a trump commercial
right keep in mind that you know if we
want to go towards more of a pure
democracy standpoint
um that if you just want to allow people
to keep voting then the idea of an
arbitrary it's it's arbitrary
to say that the american people can only
vote for somewhat someone for president
twice the founding fathers didn't
include that amendment yeah right and
that was just for these people who
want to overturn things like i mean the
gravel institute blatantly saying
constitution is trash right they hate
the electoral college
the idea that you have two term limits
like you said that's much newer
so not that i'm arguing for it i'm not
seriously arguing yeah but i'm just
saying
by their standard right and this this
actually was that this was the
the the federalist they said that yeah
there's term limits it's called
elections right that the people should
have the right to choose and that that
that was just the idea
yeah man i do find it interesting that
the executive like
you know the administrative branch got
term limits before congress that's
yeah i'm not surprised about that that's
surprising thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you